pour parler de ce pass vaccinale nous
retrouvons marcel bénézet président de
la branche cafés bars brasseries du
syndicat gmb y est également pierre
gentille et avocat au barreau de paris
messieurs bonsoir merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation ce soir pour parler de
ce pass vaccinale je me tourne d'abord
vers l'avocat pierre gentillet impasse
vaccinale donc jugée liberticide on
l'entendait par les opposants mais
validée par le conseil constitutionnel
s'était attendu
ok avec le conseil constitutionnel on
n'est jamais surpris mais on est
toujours un peu déçu parce que le rôle
du conseil constitutionnel c'est
précisément de vérifier qu'il n'y a pas
d'atteinte disproportionnée des libertés
au regard de l'objectif à atteindre je
veux dire ici se passe vaccinale il est
évidemment il constitue une atteinte aux
libertés d'aller et venir liberté de
disposer de son corps a clairement se
faire injecter un produit c'est aussi la
liberté de disposer de son corps est
tout un certain nombre de libertés
fondamentales mais le sujet ne s'arrête
pas là c'est de voir si cette atteinte
et proportionnée au regard de l'objectif
à atteindre quel est l'objectif à part
messi l'objectif visé par la loi c'est
limiter la circulation du virus c'est ça
l'objectif de la loi sauf que sauf que
ça fait des mois et des mois qu'on sait
que les non vaccinés comme les vaccinés
font circuler le virus on a 90 % de la
population thé vaccinés et qu'on a cinq
cent mille car c'est à dire dix fois
plus que les records de décembre dernier
donc tout ça démontre que le vaccin est
une arme individuelle contre la maladie
par une arme collective que le vaccin
est utile les avis des populations
fragiles pas de la majorité de la
population donc si vous voulez en termes
de disproportion de l'atteinte je crois
que là tout est caractérisée d'eau
normalement le conseil constitutionnel
aurait vu et on a été beaucoup d'avocats
il ya cent ans les droits qui en ont
parlé le conte sexuelle aurait dû bien
évidemment censurer cette loi sauf que
quand on lit la décision du conseil
constitutionnel il a refusé de se
prononcer en substance de conseil social
a dit il appartient aux gouvernants de
les mesures qu'il faut pour l'ess pour
permettre de stopper la circulation de
cette épidémie et il l'a fait en l'état
des connaissances scientifiques en fait
le conseil constitutionnel a
complètement abdiqué a complètement
démissionné lui qui s'est autoproclamé
depuis des années le garant des droits
et libertés fondamentaux puisque vous
savez que ça veut dire au masculin
et bien le conseil mensuel ici a refusé
de jouer son rôle il faut pas s'étonner
après il est une défense d'une défiance
des citoyens vis-à-vis des institutions
politiques et de l'institution
judiciaire en particulier donc moi je
vous dis je suis je suis déçu mais pas
surpris parce que je connais le conseil
qu elle je sais que c'est une
institution politique on a vu ses
précédentes des finances sur le pass
sanitaires tout ça à ma vie est assez
grave vis-à-vis de la vision qu'ont port
de l'état de droit moi à titre personnel
j'y crois plus fatigué j'avais cru
d'ailleurs mais là au moins c'est un
plaisir complètement explosé on peut
tout faire au monde une épidémie si je
termine par là aujourd'hui on le sait
n'est plus la même qu'avant 12 millions
de cas omicron ces trois dernières
semaines 200 personnes en réanimation
pour omicron est ce qu'on se rend compte
de la disproportion de la teinte et des
moyens utilisés et contenait aujourd'hui
en train de créer deux catégories de
citoyens et ce toutes les mesures folle
le les barrières aux nombreux ça est ce
qu'à un moment on va avoir la totale
disproportion le délire dans lequel nous
sommes depuis un certain temps il serait
temps w marcel bénézet je le rappelle
président de la branche cafés bars
brasseries du syndicat génie quel impact
pour vous la mise en place de ce pass
vaccinale finalement à compter de lundi
est ce que ça va changer quelque chose
par rapport aux pas salutaire pour vous
un constat chargera pas grand chose ça
ne changera pas grand chose parce que
j'ai pu comprendre tout ce que j'entends
mais où en serions nous aujourd'hui si
on n'avait pas eu au mois de juillet
l'année dernière le pass à lithaire donc
aujourd'hui peut-être que on est dans
une situation qui s'améliore parce que
le virus est beaucoup moins virulent que
le précédent mais aujourd'hui nous runo
nous ça ne change rien nous allons nous
demanderons pas la pièce d'identité la
demande roi que lorsqu'on sera on our un
doute sur le pass annie terre parce que
notre rôle n'est pas de demander de la
2e phase alité en troll je vais servir
les chaussées va là j'ai commencé perçu
c'est que c'est perçu notamment dans
votre secteur 7 cette nouvelle
disposition de goût de contrôle de
passer ni terre en cas de doute ça va
être suivi ou pas ça dans le temps dans
la lande majoritairement moi je ne
reviens pas d'obligation c'est une s'il
n'y a pas d'obligation elle va faire la
faire le contrôle d'identité mais nous
nous sommes la majorité de nos adhérents
ne le font pas ils ne feront que quand
on veut vraiment il en doute nos 90 % de
notre clientèle en ce moment sont des
habituées à paris nous l'avons plus de
touristes on a plus personne non déjà
nos commerçants sont vides alors si on
met les contraintes supplémentaires
voyez déjà quand vous donnez votre passé
le bac signale déjà vous avez l'identité
du client dessus donc elle reconnu donc
aujourd'hui c'est une contrainte
supplémentaire qui abat qui agace nous
nous nous adhérons mais le meilleur
aujourd'hui nous avons quand même des
dates lever demain le 2 février il ya
les jo d'après ce qu'une chose de plus
de georges dans les établissements vue
de marc saric de plus de max de masques
à l'extérieur le 16 le 16 février
les discothèques vont réouvrir au
pouvoir consommer debout bon voilà
aujourd'hui je vois je vois la lumière
au bout de la lorgnette c'est ce qui est
intéressant parce que la restauration
les bars et les cafés tout ce qui est
l'événement ciel dans quel état on est
aujourd'hui quand je veux dire c'est le
patron de l'établissement sont ont le
moins dans les chaussettes qu'il est
temps que ça aujourd'hui je suis très
positif je pense comment s'en sortir je
peux comprendre tous ces gens qui
manifestent je comprends très bien mais
la liberté c'est de faire ce qu'on a
envie de faire ils veulent passer leurs
latine et ils seront pas vaccinés moi je
me suis fait vacciner c'est mon droit
aussi cela dans chacun est libre de
faire ce qu'il obtient gentillet
justement non n'est pas libre on fait un
choix justement c'est pas l'autorisation
d'avoir pour la liberté aujourd'hui la
société du passé ah non monsieur je suis
pas d'accord avec vous en l'occurrence
qu'on vous dit vous et puis bah nous on
n'est pas libre parce que sinon canton
et non vaccinés on est isolé socialement
et ensuite monsieur le chantage entre
soi c'est le confinement soit c'est le
pass vaccinale moi j'aime regarder et
pays qui ont fait ni l'un ni l'autre sap
a été le la mort partout dans les rues
la suède n'a pas confiner la semaine n'a
pas mis passe en vigueur dans ces
établissements ou s'agissant des
déplacements et la suède ne s'est pas
transformé en mouroir donc faut arrêter
d'arbitrer entre deux mesures
restrictives et c'est à dire oh la la
heureusement qu'on a impasse parce que
sinon on serait confinée ça c'est du
chantage et là malheureusement je suis
désolé monsieur mais vous fait avoir je
vous le dis très gentiment par le ce que
ce que vous dites gouvernement nous
n'avons pas accepté toutes ces mesures
aujourd'hui il ya le vaccin les gens qui
veulent c'est à vacciner se font
vacciner le reste de la population
revis ya pas avoir un pass ya pas exiger
un passe d'autant que le pass c'est le
début de quelque chose aujourd'hui se
passe on le met c'est le sens d'un
statut vaccinal demain je vous le dit on
le mettra pour un pass écologique ou le
mettra pour un pass pénal on le mettra
pour tout un tas de deux problématiques
et on avancera progressivement vers le
crédit social chinois relativement on y
arrivera donc il faut voir ce vers quoi
nous allons aller donc moi je pense que
ces gens ont raison de manifester je
pense que nous allons vers quelque chose
de dangereux il me semble qu'il faut à
faire attention il faut être très
critique vis-à-vis du gouvernement parce
que non seulement il a mal géré la crise
alors je ne suis pas en train de dire
que je leur ai géré moi mais je vois ce
qui s'est passé je vois le danger qui
arrive devant nous je vois toutes les
privations de liberté je vois la société
d'autorisation et de contrôle d avance
et je bois et c'est ça ce qui m'inquiète
beaucoup plus que le gouvernement je
vois que les gens sont de plus en plus
passif est de plus en plus qu'on
s'entend parce qu'ils en ont marre et
parce qu'ils se disent après tout
abdiquons acceptons se passe renonçant à
une partie de notre liberté soyons moins
vigilants mais non ça s'arrêtera pas
marcel à rezai pour conclure vous vous
confirmer que ce pass sanitaire
finalement il a sauvé votre activité
pendant pendant ces dernières semaines
c'est au tour surtout depuis le mois de
juillet au mois de juillet l'année 2,7
de l'année dernière on n'avait pas le
choix ce n'est pas le passé ni t on
risque et les fermetures administratives
n'ont donc donc le confinement ou dont
les établissements dont n'avait pas le
choix mais effectivement peut-être
monsieur raison mais celle ci s'est les
historiens critiques écran la suite
aujourd'hui la suite on la connaît pas
chaque jour il ya de la polémique
partout aujourd'hui le bleu le savez il
est facile facile de ne s'était pas
facile de cette femme et moi je
reconnais à gérer je dis pas qui a tort
qui a raison c'est très difficile
aujourd'hui on s'en sort pas trop mal
j'espère qu'on va s'en sortir et je suis
très positif c'est vrai que je suive un
jour à ces gens qui veulent pas se faire
vacciner c'est leur choix mais les
priver de effectivement vous avez raison
que les privés c'est peut-être c'est
difficile pour eux je suis l'accord
aussi mais bon maintenant il faut que
nous on a du personnel dans des
entreprises il faut qu'on travaille
aujourd'hui on a besoin de travailler on
a énormément besoin de travailler merci
à tous les deux en tout cas d'avoir
accepté d'échanger de débattre en direct
sur arte france merci à vous hier le
gentillet avocat au barreau de paris
merci marcel bénézet président de la
branche cafés bars brasseries du
sanitaire génie